I actually was going to be
this februari to make the same speech
and now I've changed it slightly because
of some of the progress we've made in
this area but and some of the things
that I thought would be interesting i
added to the speech but actually we
couldn't make it because of a snowstorm
in February and so it's taken us some
time to reschedule but I'm really happy
to be here when my predecessor then the
late Roberta goes where a Cocola
chairman and CEO worked worked with Yale
to first establish the world fund back
in 1992 I think the world was a very
different place in fact I'm feeling
Asian just thinking about this but in
1992 I think many of you in this room
probably weren't in kindergarten yet but
one thing that has not changed since
then is the enormous need in my opinion
enormous need to cultivate greater
global awareness cultivate more cross
cultural programs stronger relations
internationally and also to cultivate
more and astute global leaders political
leaders business leaders and so forth
and I think no institution in the world
has done more to advance this mission
nor is better prepared to lead this
charge I think in the coming years than
Yale University I should also tell you
that I you know I'm also sometimes
surrounded by elys at coca-cola I've
brought a couple along Clyde Tuggle here
whose global head of public affairs and
communication for the coca-cola company
as a former alumni I've got Andrew
Angela Harrell here who's not only at
Yale alumni but also a coca-cola scholar
very we're very proud of that program
through the years we've been fortunate
to
ooh a number of Yale graduates to our
company and we thank also Yale
University for their your contribution
your wonderful contribution to taking
and accepting and many coca-cola
scholars and also bring them into the
world as better people who will become
no question as to global leaders i also
have a personal connection to yale
university my late father-in-law
professor ilhan luton studied law and
taught here at yale before embarking on
a long and distinguished career in and
both international relations as well as
as well as human rights working for many
years at the united nations leading
their charge globally in human rights
and his beautiful daughter definite my
wife is also here and my partner for the
past 31 years and in this context of
people of family of international
relationships and human rights in a year
following the 40th anniversary of
co-education here at yale i would like
to begin this discussion today about the
future of our global economy as well as
the future of our global society
specifically i'd like to talk about
women and i'm so happy to see so many
here not in the audience today women
play a transformative role in our global
economy in our global society over the
next decade not too long just let's
focus on our time horizon i also want to
share some thoughts on the role women
will play in helping transform my
company the coca-cola company and the
coca-cola system globally over the next
decade
just a few days ago driving to work
stuck in atlanta traffic my attention
turned to a report about China about a
month ago and I'm chairman of the US
China Business Council and a time time
something pops up about China obviously
not just because of the important to my
our business but also because of that
role that I play is the head of the US
China Business Council I listen very
carefully some economists that were
predicting that by the end of the year
it will 2010 will be the first year
calendar year when the Chinese economy
would eclipse that of Japan and move
into a comfortable number two position
and the child and certainly that is
happening it's happened essentially
nothing will reverse that and day
doesn't go by without some new
breathtaking statistic about China about
India about Brazil or some other
fast-growing emerging economy in the
world and I think no one has done
actually a better job in my opinion then
talking about eloquently writing about
the economic rise of the rest of the
world then Yale's own Fareed Zakaria who
i've come to know pretty well I've had
the good fortune of being with him on a
number of occasions and I'm very
impressed by his fascinating insights
and into his wonderful book the
post-american world he wrote at length
about the nation's those nations that
will be driving the 21st century and the
21st century economy and the
implications that all of that is going
to have on our nation here in America
and I think there's another way of
looking at this as well that goes beyond
national comparisons beyond national
economies and what they stand for in
fact I would say that the real drivers
of the post-american world
I believe won't be China won't be India
won't be Brazil won't be any nation the
real drivers are going to be women I
think women leaders women entrepreneurs
women business political academic
cultural leaders and of course women
innovators the truth is women already
are one of the most the fastest-growing
dynamic economic force in the world
today women now control over 20 trillion
dollars in spending worldwide 20
trillion dollars spending worldwide US
economy roughly 13 trillion dollars this
much more to the story though here in
the US alone women-owned businesses
account for nearly four trillion dollars
in GDP and and again that would
constitute based on the latest numbers
despite the growth in China actually
equal third or fourth-largest economy in
the world and women entrepreneurship
doesn't stop at the US borders of course
its soaring all around the world in fact
today one in 11 working age women is now
women are involved in entrepreneurship
in the world and the highest percentages
actually of women business owners are in
markets that you probably would not
expect unless you actually drove deep
into that subject consider this alone
just nearly twenty percent of working
women in Thailand I entrepreneurs twenty
percent in India it's fourteen percent
Argentina twelve percent Brazil it's
eleven percent Mexico and Chile ten
percent and so on so let's for the
moment actually forget all the talk
about the China century or the brick
century the real story is that the 21st
century I believe is going to be the
women's century
as the world desperately pretty
desperately actually looks for ways to
restart re-engage reset the global
economy the solution I think lies right
in front of us in the world words of the
World Bank President Robert Zoellick
gender equality he says is simply quote
unquote smart economics now I realize
that some of you may be scratching your
head and saying why is this guy coming
here and talking to us about women well
you know firstly I've been managed by
women all my life beginning with my
mother then my wife then my daughter and
I think you know they've done an okay
job so far my daughter selling is that
in our early stages of her professional
career I'd like to actually see her also
flourish and in a world that is actually
more just more equitable for women than
it is today I also feel a deep and
personal obligation to uphold legacies
of men of great principal who work
before me at the coca-cola company and
who were in my family before who
promoted the rights of all men and women
equally and of course as a business
leader in someone actually personally
who has been given the responsibility of
creating shareholder value for the
world's most recognized brand I feel a
tremendous sense of urgency in ensuring
that conditions are ripe for women to
thrive around the world call it's
self-interest call it smart economics it
to me actually is is just makes business
sense creating a climate of success I
think for women globally is just as I
said smart business it's smart business
for any company for not just consumer
products companies for any company I
think you empower women and you actually
recharge the world in the last few
months few weeks magazines ranging from
the Economist to Businessweek have cited
so many studies that show direct
correlation the good regression actually
between women's and women empowerment
and GDP growth around the world between
women empowerment and business success
between women empowerment and health and
sustainability between women empowerment
and also improved human health across
the world so if you take the community
social family all implications are vast
positive and vast there's no question
also that women actually impact the
public opinion inside the home you know
we at coca-cola something you know one
of the things that we do a lot is do a
lot of research about our consumers
about how they think how what's on their
mind what excites them what inspires
them and basically women determine we
know women determine what comes into the
home we know that globally seventy
percent of our shoppers are women of the
1.6 billion servings that we consumers
invite our products into their lives
every day seventy percent of the of
those decisions are taken by women and
we know therefore that we cannot grow
our business unless the people the
700,000 people that work for the
coca-cola system globally in 206
countries are representative of those
numbers and they are not representative
and that's why it big
a very important and a priority for me
to close that bridge and we know that
that's a journey so based on that
premise that no business can grow
successfully unless they close that
bridge and also all the growth based on
the fact that all the growth projections
we've been hearing about for the coming
years for China for Africa for India for
North and South America none of it is
really going to be possible without
women's economic empowerment more
success in women's economic empowerment
we also talked in coca-cola a lot about
a billion new people coming into the
middle class over the next decade a
billion new people coming into the
middle class over the next decade the
only way that the world and that's going
to add another twenty trillion to the
world in terms of richness the only way
that's going to happen the only way more
nations are going to rise out of poverty
the only way that the same trends that
China was able to successfully achieve
over the last ten years in terms of
bringing people out of poverty is only
going to be possible if more women are
empowered successfully and I think again
by the same token if we fail at that
certainly that growth is not going to
take place certainly those 1 billion
people are not going to come out and
join the middle class we still see too
many roadblocks to women's empowerment
what are those cultural roadblocks
educational roadblocks political
roadblocks financial roadblocks
technology roadblocks recently I had a
great great conversation with our
presidents ambassador-at-large for
global global woman issues moline
verveer ambassador of every year she
said something very that's resonated
with me a lot she said too many quote
too many of the best business ideas died
in bank
parking lots she said unquote and again
she was referring to the financial
roadblocks when she mentioned when she
was quoted saying that so what I'd like
to do over the next few minutes is
outlined three concrete ways that I
believe both business government and
also academia can have in terms of a
significant impact in generating female
empowerment around the globe and I think
my hope is that you know you think that
these ideas regardless of whether your
career takes you into business
government academic or non-profit
pursuits I think can be applicable I
think though one of the criteria
important criteria is that there has to
be better cooperation amongst three key
stakeholders for this to happen that is
government business and civil society we
need I call it the Golden Triangle I
think we need more corporation
collaboration concrete collaboration
between government business and civil
society for the things that i am going
to outline to enable the things that i'm
going to outline so let me just say what
those are number one the first way we
can help fuel women's empowerment i
think is the most obvious that is
accelerating women's leadership within
our own four walls I mean you can't sit
here talk about the importance of this
unless you're doing something inside
your own four walls I think one of the
most fulfilling programs I am personally
involved with at coca-cola is the
Women's Leadership Council that we
formed about three and a half years ago
it rotates every two years we have about
15 16 women leaders on this council the
chairman of this council currently cathy
waldor who's the global controller of
coca-cola is right here with me sure
raise your head
every number we put out talk about our
business she's behind that number and
when she's behind that number i'm
comfortable because i don't go to jail
and she is also she also heads up the
Women's Leadership Council right now for
the past year and a half very
successfully and what what this council
does is it acts as mentors it identifies
mid-level women leaders brings them in
develops them tracks their success and
and make sure that the senior leadership
of the company is always appraised of
new opportunities in this area and also
certainly we keep track of metrics in
how we're doing at senior levels
mid-level management and also recruiting
women leaders into the company so
recruit develop train and ensure that we
can promote and retain those are the I
think one of the things that we also
have to do better as a as a goal in
ensuring that we can be more successful
in women leadership is ensuring that we
have across all geographies a good
work-life balance that's one of the key
sometimes what we found is one of the
key barriers in ensuring developing and
promoting women leaders flexible work
arrangements again mobility has been
sometimes an area of focus for us
opportunity for us so in addition to
everything we're doing we've we've grown
the number of women in upper management
level positions across our company and
our female employment employees
engagement scores are much higher than
they were 23 years ago and today we do
have one
and leaders in in many posts in addition
to Cathy Wohlers posts our chief people
officer globally is a woman leader
president of coca-cola Europe which is
one of our five operating units globally
is a Frenchwoman leader the head of our
North American sparkling business is a
woman leader the head of our joint
venture with Nestle for ready to drink
teas globally beverage partners
worldwide is a woman leader from Germany
the head of coca-cola turkey is a woman
leader one of our top bottlers around
the world in China is headed by a woman
leader and so on and so forth I can
count many the the point about all of
this is that we're not where we want to
be this is not a victory lap we're
certainly on a journey and we're getting
better but we're not where we need to be
and certainly I hold myself accountable
for us getting better in this area as
does my entire than remaining nine
members of my executive team we have
very aggressive metrics in coca-cola in
place and we have a vision which we call
2020 vision for roadmap for winning
together with our bottling partners
based on the metrics in that vision we'd
up we will double our business between
now and 2020 we're also in the inside
that same vision pushing ourselves to be
amongst the best places to work we're
pushing ourselves to be more consumer
focused more community focused more
environmentally focused and we know that
we can't do any of that without greater
participation of women then today we
have to get better at that both at
senior ranks mid-level management and
also entry level and so it that piece of
women leadership is mission critical and
that's why
we had a lot of debate when I when we
were designing that mission two years
ago when I brought all my bottling
partners from all around the world
together into Florida to craft and
design that vision which we call 2020
now and I specifically ensured that
women leadership was written on that one
page in that vision statement not about
equality not about in more broad words
women leadership and the keen insights
woman bring to our business there for
you know once again for us are profound
and again that was the message that i
took to Davos earlier this year at the
World Economic Forum when I appeared on
a gender parity panel discussion with
Arianna Huffington and also facebook CEO
Sheryl Sandberg the doubt that panel was
broadcast then at on CNBC I actually
would like to share just a very short
clip with our audience of that panel
then in Davos this year in January
sahaja I think it's all about
understanding of what's going to work
for your business in the next 10 to 20
years and really drive value if you can
push through a cultural change that
makes your company understand that
there's going to be half a billion new
women middle class and coming into the
middle class in the next 10 to 15 years
in the world and you need to communicate
understand better matched their
expectations and therefore you need
really a much more effective result in
terms of women leadership in your
organization across the world and that
is sustainability a quota will never
sustain you I think it's really
important you know goals not quotas as a
woman in the workforce some 40 years old
I hope to be in the workforce a long
time I never want to get a job because
they have to have me I want to get a job
because I earn it and quotas naked
quoted quotas do that I think goals are
different and I think the really
important thing and once again excited
about what coca-cola's doing is putting
communication on the table that was
about a sort of an hour long panel but I
just wanted you to get a glimpse of it
was a lively discussion and another
theme that was actually echoed in that
discussion was the importance of
bringing more women owned businesses
into our supply chains into our global
supply chains as companies which is I
think the second area important area
where again that triangle government
business civil society I think can make
some pretty impactful change positive
change because of the global reach
because of the influence of our
operations worldwide companies like us
are powerful agents of constructive
change one of the most exciting I think
women's entrepreneurial development
programs that i have been involved in so
far at coca-cola is our micro
distribution center network in africa
this program of micro distribution
center network allows us to identify and
support independent entrepreneurs to set
up distribution centers on behalf of our
business but they don't exclusively
distribute coca-cola products Micro
distribution centers are typically
located in Africa in areas where there
there's a lack of infrastructure lack of
stable roads and it makes us it very
difficult for us to get to to distribute
our products with normal vehicles and
normal distribution means and this
independent network of distributors they
just start distributing coca-cola's
beverage products
to retailers often by push carts or
bicycles because no other vehicles can
actually negotiate the infrastructure
that exists in place and in fact the
vast majority of our sales today after
about seven eight years of us investing
in this entrepreneurial system and
project in Kenya Tanzania Uganda
Ethiopia opia Mozambique and some other
countries vast majority of our business
is distributed through this network now
we have in total now about three and a
half thousand of these entrepreneurial
projects in operation in Africa
employing more than 20,000 people the
most important piece however is that a
thousand of these are owned and operated
by women I made a commitment again at
the CGI clinton global initiative that
we would at least ensure that at least
half of them half of these would be
women going forward and we've been very
successful the metrics we've achieved
and surpassed our goals in that area and
and it's it's beautiful to see how how
successful some of these women
entrepreneurs have become all across
Africa much more successful than
actually their male counterparts and
their connection how the world works is
so fascinating through our water
sustainability programs in Africa where
we take clean water to certain villages
in Africa which don't have clean
hygienic water and in Africa remember
that lack of clean water kills more
people than malaria and HIV combined so
we threw water replenishing projects we
call it rain replenish Africa initiative
we bring clean water to some villages
water harvesting project will harvest
rain
we captured the rain that normally comes
but it's not cat is not captured we have
irrigation projects and so on and so
forth women then become emancipated
because it's the women who you are
carrying water from 10 miles away to
their village clean water from another
town 10 miles away once women become
emancipated we then go in and try to get
a break down some of the other barriers
for women entrepreneurship and
empowerment like financial barriers
cultural barriers give them training at
basic accounting training give them
merchandising training stock rotation
training and they become fascinatingly
successful in in we now have these
projects in more than 11 countries in
Africa just one example you know one of
her one of these entrepreneurs rosemary
nigiri down and down in downtown nairobi
running one of these micro distribution
centers very loyal to our staff has
grown her business so successful that
today she employs 16 people some of whom
have worked with her since she started
way back on day one and two of her sales
people now have built their own homes
from the income that they have earned
from rosemary so you know and and we can
have you know just thousands of examples
of people as I said 20,000 people work
for 3,000 of these micro distribution
projects today across our entire global
supply chain of coca-cola supply chain
upwards of 10 million women we have
upwards of 10 million women owned or
women operated businesses from suppliers
distributors retailers that derive a
meaningful portion of their income from
coca-cola around the world we know that
there's a lot more to do and that's why
a couple of weeks ago we launched a new
commitment called five
by 20 and that is to empower 5 million
more women by 2020 through again our
entire global supply chain again you
know that may sound bo bold but we
believe we can do it with focus with
more collaboration between ourselves
governments and civil society in all the
countries that we do business in
expanding the models in Africa to India
to other parts of Asia to Indonesia to
other countries in Latin America we
believe we can get to that goal and
surpass that goal of empowering an
additional five million women
entrepreneurs operators on top of the
ones that we have so far empowered
globally up to now and again it's all
about getting rid of those barriers that
I've talked about barriers to credit
like the discussion that we've had with
Ambassador Vermeer a peer networking
basic training and again in experience
from Africa tells us that all the
training that we give on accounting
business planning simple basics of
marketing basics of stock rotation
merchandising customer service legal
advice all work wonderfully for these
women entrepreneurs now you know again I
have to you know just let me be clear
that all of this initiative is going to
also reach millions and millions of men
who are part of this vast network so all
boats are going to rise you know this is
this is not about just you know
exclusively doing this for women but the
important thing is when you focus you
put metrics you hold yourself
accountable then you achieve your
results which leads me to again that now
the third area in which business
government and civil society can help
promote global women's economic impact
empowerment and that is by staying
committed to sustainability initiatives
in this economic environment that we
have today there's been a lot of
discussion all across our world the
business world about cutting back on
sustainability initiatives because of
the situation that business finds itself
in today's current economy especially in
the Western world and that's extent you
know we believe it coca-cola that that
is extremely short-sighted and is
exactly today is the time to recommit to
these initiatives critical initiatives
whether it is educational initiatives or
environmental programs or human health
programs cultural programs economic
development initiatives and so forth
everything is interrelated and and as
you may imagine from what I just
mentioned on the micro distribution
projects we are passionate about water
water is a huge focus of sustainability
efforts at coca-cola it is central to
our business and to our future that's
why we have come out and put a stake in
the ground and said we will be water
neutral by the year twenty twenty years
coca-cola what that means is that for
every litre of water that we use to make
our beverages any kind of are any one of
our three thousand different beverages
that we will give back that one liter
for every liter we will give back and
you'll say how do you do that what we do
it through three simple means we reduce
the amount of water we through
technology instead of rinsing our
bottles for example we will use air in
many of the new technologies we
replenish water through water
replenishment projects capture rainwater
give back and then we recycle the water
and give back to the municipalities as
clean water to those are the three ways
and we have reduced our water by twenty
percent over the last five years we will
reduce our water further twenty plus
percent in the next four years and we
will become watering
through by 2020 water is also
fundamental to women's economic
empowerment as I mentioned before just
one simple link in terms of how you
emancipate women in Africa through
bringing water and how you can then
start empowering them so this sort of
brings us full cycle smart organizations
I think those that succeed over the next
decade and beyond will understand that
the 21st century is the women's century
women's economic empowerment and
entrepreneurial growth will drive I
believe the world's economy it's not a
matter of if but a matter of 21 height
not a matter of if so for all of us in
business education government civil
society the implications I think are
going to be very vast very profound I
think everyone's success I believe is
going to be contingent upon woman's
success and we think that way and unless
you think that way I don't think you can
do justice to the opportunity so and and
again let me be clear this is not a
battle of the sexes it is not far from
it this is actually a battle for
preserving and enhancing the world's
economic environmental and social fabric
so it's that simple no one knows this I
think more what I just said then all of
you here at Yale which I think has
flourished to an incredible level of
height since you have gone
co-educational 40 years ago and I
therefore wish you all the best of
success in your future role in ensuring
that the 21st century will be the
women's
so thank you for giving me this
opportunity all of you and it's been a
great pleasure and honor to be here
today thank you